Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier
and welcome to "A Trip to Yugoslavia".
This is supposedly a horror game made in, like, the VHS era
and it's supposed to feature, like, "live-action" stuff.
Now, I don't know if that means MOVIES,
or if that just means PICTURES,
but it's about going to a place ya shouldn't go...
"WARNING:
"This is a choice based game, in which your decisions will change the outcome of others."
"The game saves automatically after you make a decision..."
Oookay!
"This game isn't based on any real conflict in Yugoslavia."
Alrighty then!
I have no idea how this is gonna go. But it was highly rated,
and it seemed really interesting, like, taking these things
from a different perspective. There's always, like,
uh...the--the--the--Power Drill Massacre that was
really cool in this, like, old-style of horror stuff. So,
uh, speaking of which, I always meant to finish
Power Drill Massacre, but I wasn't sure...
Oh, it does! Oh, why am I--is that me?
Oh!
Ow, my--ow, my head!
Okay...
Oh, that's just a preview of everything to come. I thought that was--okay I'm an idiot! Okay, here we go!
I thought that was happening now.
So...
(deeper voice) What are we doing?
(guitar music)
Oh, it's beautiful!
Oh, it's gorgeous!
Oh, cool!
Is this Yugoslavia?
Hello!
How are you?
Ya having a good time?
Probably not about to, but maybe now; it's pretty nice with the scenery and everything.
(music stops)
Uh, oh!
Who the hell is that?
Why's he in the middle of the road?
Also, why are you in the middle of the road?
I noticed he had a camer--Whoa!
Okay, hi! Hi friend, how ya doin'? Am I dead? (heartbeats)
Oh, no, I'm just in trouble.
Ow!
What's the—wha—ow...okay, alright, step and my hand and then step on my face.
That's really nice of you guys.
What a warm welcome to Yugoslavia!
Oh, okay.
Alright, so this is where the choices come into play.
Now, I've never played this before, and I have no idea.
All I'm gonna do is, I'm gonna apply my wise logic.
He's asleep! I should take his gun!
Murder him, then run away!
Although, making any noise would probably be a very bad idea...
OK...quick time events?
Anything?
What do I do?!?!
I don't know...
Okay...alright...you...okay...alright...you...okay...
Are you gonna try to seduce him?
Whaaat...?
Oh, he has a knife. Oh, OK.
Ah! Yeah! That was smart!
Uhhhooohhh!!!
Wait...Was I supposed to do something?
Uh oh.
Is he gonna die?
Wait, what was I supposed to do?!
(Kidnapper speaks garble)
*Nervous grunt*
(gunshot) Uh oh.
I spit at his face, I think.
What? "It's not going to be that easy. Pay attention and you might survive."
But what was I supposed to do! I didn't see any quick-time evenntts!
What happened??
"Rewind the tape using left shift and try again."
Oh, maybe that was important because that was the tutorial,
and that was telling me what happens if I don't do it,
'cause otherwise, I might be an idiot,
and I have no idea what I'm doing...
So, left shift rewinds,
so hopefully....
Oooohhhh!
Ah, right shift, OK!
Oh, that's cool!
Oh, that's cool.
They really nailed the effects of VHS fast forwarding.
Ok, here we go.
Now...
What--what...up...
Okay, I upped it!
I upped real good!
I got the ups!
I got all the ups!
Also, why did they kill me just because I was trying to escape?
Why didn't they kill me before then?
Aren't--am I a valuable prisoner or am I not?
Was this something?
I'm paying attention.
I'm focusing!
All of my powers, invested in this moment.
Almost there!
Ughhh....
Gonna get it--Oh, I'm free then...Okay, never mind.
Uh huh...
Ohh, don't act like it was hard to breathe in that thing!
You've got a perfectly good nose.
Alright.
Oh, he looks a little young to be a soldier, but--
I'm gonna give him the benefit of the doubt! Oh yeah. That's a nice gun. Woo!
Ooh!
"I'm not a fan of this decision, but getting rid of the guard means one less problem?"
"I should escape while I can, but both of the guards will come after me."
Well, I mean, obviously!
I mean, duh!
You gotta g--Oh, he's just sleeping! (somber music starts) Oh, he's probably not even the one that...
Ohhh that's so--oooh,
That's grim!
Oh, that's really grim.
Hehh!
Ah...
Oh, really?
Oh, you're not gonna do it?
Oh, you're gonna wimp out.
Oh, you just wasted time!
Ohh, you're gonna wimp out like a little baby!
Ohh, what a baby.
Ah, man, that's not a choice! You just made a choice for me!
C'mon, man. You gotta be better--ooh.
(crunch, chase music)
Wha--I did--What! What??!
That's some intense thumping music, but I didn't even know--
Okay, so, the symbols mean certain things,
but I've done goofed, because I didn't know that I was supposed to go to the right.
Well...
Oh, he's pissin'... I, actu--*laugh* I unlocked an achievement!
Running away like a little bitch baby!
As fast as I can, and making as much noise as I can!
Oh, now I'm just depressed.
And I think my foot hurts from stepping on that stick!
Alright, man.
Ya gotta--
Ya gotta do me proud here; you're making me look bad!
Alright, c'mon.
C'mon.
C'mon!
I might go back and fix everything, but for right now, c'mon.
C'mon, whaddya gonna do?
You gonna do a quick-time event?
Heh?
You just gonna stand there awkwardly. Okay.
"I could take him out before he notices, but he could use his rifle against me?"
"Maybe I should take his rifle away first, but if he notices..."
Yeahh, I'm thinkin' getting shot in the face by a rifle isn't a good choice.
How 'bout I go with the bashing him...with the butt!
Bash him.
Butt bash him!
Pretty much the preview of the--
(laughs) Hey!
Hey, look over here as I smack ya in the face!
Okay, ladadadada...
Okay, let me loot his wallet here,
because that's probably what I came here for.
Oh boy, double gunning!
Yeah. Yup, he's dead alright.
Ok, moving along.
Boy, that guy was ugly,
and that was a long piss.
Alright, (starts laughing)
Off we go then!
I guess that was a good choice.
My camera should be around here somewhere.
"Photos of surrounding areas should be on it and they might come in handy..."
So, you're a journalist?
"If I make it out alive I'll show the world what happened here."
I got kidnapped!
I don't know why!
Oh, am I--
Oh!
"Enter chamber"?
"Enter chamber"!?
I don't like the--I don't like the sound of "chamber".
Okay, this ones got an eyeball,
or a boob!
And it's surrounded by mickey mooses.
This one's got a cat, and then a guy!
Lookin' out, real scary-like!
So, I'm thinking there's a guard behind that one!
I'm gonna go with the boob and the rat.
Uh-oh.
There's nothing in here.
"UWAGA"!
"INWAZA"!
Okay--ah, a window!
Hello?
"A window covered in dust."
Is it a boob or that an eye?
I can never tell.
Okay, there's nothing here. What about this other one?
Oooh, what was that?
Camera! Okay, got it!
Am I good?
Okay.
Well, that doesn't sound good!
Ow!
Ow!?? Am I dying?!
Okay...
"Progress saved"! Yeah!
I think--I don't know--what else we're doing here.
Oh, now, I'm sad!
Wait, where'd my rifle go?
I have--
A hundred and eleven bullets in one magazine.
Uh...
I don't like where this is going.
What---
Huh?
What?
Safety toggle? Oh, that--that's probably important! Yeah, we need that!
Okay, so safety has been "toogled".
"Flip handgun."
Okay.
Oh, this is so weird, the actual maintenance on the handgun.
Okay, "check magazine".
Okay, I'll do that. What happened to your finger?!
When did that happen?
How many "roons" (rounds)?
How many bull-lets?
How many--killy-killy, shooty-shooty, bang-bangers?
Am I--am I good?
Te--"Test the gun"...I don't think that's a good idea.
Well, sounds like it's gonna make a lot of noise and that's probably a wast a bull--
I'm not gonna do that, even though it's the only choice presented in front of me.
Okay, wh--
Why not?!
(laughs) Why not!?
Heh. Oh--(laughs) Oh, that was--that was a good one! That was a good one!
Here. let's try that again with a little more "Ooomph!"
Oh...
Smart...don't shoot your balls off.
Yeah, no one will notice that.
No one will notice that!
You're the stealthiest reporter to ever go to Yugoslavia!
Okay, grassland...
tense in the distance, mansion...
What is over the mansion? Is that a helicopter?
Okay.
So we got. "It's some kind of mansion. The helicopter above it..."
Tense in the distance...
"It's a camp. Can't see very well from here."
So....I'm guessing there's probably a lot of military people over there.
So, I can go in the grassland, or I can go in the forest.
Something tells me the forest is probably gonna be more secluded, and harder to find me in...
Okay.
Forest.
"There's no need to go forward. I think I am safe for now..."
Oh.
What!?
You think you're safe!? Why?
Why do you think you're safe? You got kidnapped!
Let's see.
"The season is taking it's toll."
Oooh-kay...
Oh, bi-nocs.
Oh, good, I found bi-nocs!
Okay, so I should be able to see something now!
(grunts)
If I squeeze my eyes real hard....
"It's empty as well...what's going on? Are they moving out?"
I guess...
How about the mansion?
Oh! "It's empty. How so?"
How's it empty! I see a dude right there! And a motorcycle!
And a whole bunch of stuff!
How're you gonna tell it's empty!
Okay then...
So, forest. "The forest seems a bit dense around this area."
Good! Great camouflage!
Oh! Hello! Where were you--Where did you come from!
You weren't there before!
Okay then...
They're after me!
Oh, shit!
They've spotted me!
With THEIR bi-nocs!
Oh, God!
Okay, so, forest...
Forest? Okay, in the forest.
Okay, good.
I made the right choice here.
Obviously. (grunts)
(action music starts)
Hi.
Oh, hell yeah!
(taunting) You can't catch me!
Not even with your bullets!
Oh, geeze, uh, left!
Yeah!!
Oh, ba-BOOM!
I got you good! Well...
They're both still there...Okay, well...
They're--They're both alive and not dead.
(action music continues)
Okay...
Heh! Up!
I got--(laughs) I gotcha...
Oh! Oh, no! Ow! (laughs) Oooh! Ooof! Ow!
That--that--that winded me a little bit! Oooh!
Ow!
Ooh!
I guess he's okay, though, apparently.
Maybe I just got a BB gun and they're just really scared of it.
Okay.
(action music stops)
(gasps) Oh, shit, dude!
Uh, oh.
(heartbeats)
Down?
Yeah, that's down!
Why are they just standing there! (gunshot)
Huh, bang!
Oh, no! Oh, ew! Oh, ah! Ugh, eee!
I need to lie down for a moment!
I jus--I just need to catch my breath!
Okay.
Well, I got him.
Too bad they didn't use their guns on me!
That woulda been a shame!
(sad music plays)
Oh.
Here we are, wherever this--
Wha-what happened to you?!
Did you get shot?!
They didn't use their guns once! I watched!
Oh, well.
Hope you're okay...both limping, AND holding your arm.
How'd, uh...did they--did they just stream a line of bullets down your right side,
completely, but is was all flesh wounds all across the surface?
Ohhh, and now you're passing out.
What--what an adventure.
He--he's all tuckered out.
"It was too late to run away."
Oooooohhhuuuhhh!
"The entire town was overrun by enemy soldiers."
OOHHHHH!
"I decide to stay low, behind the enemy lines. Hoping that I could get back home."
(squeak)
"But that's when I knew..."
I was...
"The war has begun..."
War were declared!
Five--Oh! "Five months later"! Oh, we're fast-forwarding!
Oh, okay! (laughs)
I've got a ghillie suit, just made completely out of bushes!
They'll never see me!
I've got my pellet gun!
Oh, I'll getcha!
But I'm not gonna hesitate this time!
You're in for it!
I'm comin' for ya!
Yeah!!!
You'll never hear me comin' when I'm yelling!
I'm 'onna murder ya!
Where's the murder! "The guard might not be malicious, maybe I should just knock him out?"
NO!!!
I'm gonna murder him where he stands!
This time, I'm not gonna miss!
Not today! (intelligible)
Arrrghh, stab!!!
With the back of my knife!
You know, I'm Rurouni Kenshin.
I never kill.
Oh, he's dead. Am I gonna pull out like a,
like a--like a picture of his family or something?
Oh, okay.
Okay. Alright. Well...
Time to decorate my home some more.
That I've been living in for five months.
They'll never notice that one of their soldiers have been gone dead.
But if I'd-a just knocked him out, then he might have come after me
So, I think it's probably for the best.
Well, now that I got a rifle back,
because somehow I lost it--oooh, oh!
Uh oh.
There's something over the horizon. I'm gonna get it.
Ohhhh...I'm readying my fightin' fists!
Oooooh, it's those chambers I remember.
Oh!
Oh, well, that's no good!
Well, that's pretty grim!
Okey-dokey, then!
Is that a sniper rifle in the back, there?
So one of them might be a "snaper"....
Alright, well...
What am I doin'?
Was I just so appalled by it?
Let's see...
"A melee weapon could be useful, but I could risk getting spotted."
"I should leave while I still have the chance, but other than this rifle; I don't have any other weapon."
Whaddya know?!?!
Having a rifle seems like a pretty good idea for a weapon...
I'm not a 100% sure about things,
but, you know, as far as a kalashnikov goes...
Not the worst thing in the world! So...
I'm gonna be stupid and go for the melee weapon.
Let's do iiiiiitttttttttttttttttttttt!!!!!!
C'mon, is there a quick-time event?
I wanna get this. I wanna do this.
I wanna get it. I wanna get it.
I wanna get it.
Ehh. eehh. Just gotta watch this terrain.
Ooh! Sprained my ankle a little bit over there!
Oh, don't worry about me, though.
I've taken, like, dozens of bullets just to my right side, but...
This is the first time my left side got hurt, so I think I'll be okay!
(grunts)
The sneakiest, sneakiest journalist that ever did live...
I haven't managed to get a gun except for this one moment, five months later...
I'm gonna get it. (smacks lips)
I'm gonna flank left, I'm gonna dodge to the right...
I'm gonna do a somersault,
and then spin my ribbon baton, and then hopefully,
you know,
maybe sleep with one of the judges and then get a high score!
But for now, I'm gonna get this!
Okay...
Yeah, bypass that machine gun on the ground there.
Bypass the sniper rifle.
Go for the shovel!
This is totally worth the shovel!
Why would they--
Why--why would they just stand there, talking?
We're going to have a conversation away from these dead bodies; the smell is really getting to me!
Alright.
"I should run while they are distracted. I have a lower chance of getting shot while I am running."
"Sneaking away is risky, but if they don't turn around I should be able to get away safe."
Okay, so it's either:
guaranteed they look,
or, you know, maybe they don't look.
Ah, they're probably gonna look!
Eh, they don't have the guns with them...
Run! Run! Run! Run like the--Run like the little baby you are!
RUN!!!!
Run harder!!
Run!
Uh, ba-bang! Oooh, Ew, ah!
Oh! (coughs) Oh!
Oh! Ohhh! Eeww! Awwwww!!
It didn't work! Oh, God! My spine!
Well..
That sucks! Okay, let's rewind it, here!
Wait, no.
Forward it there...
(fast forwarding voice sounds)
What?
Awww, get away from your schticky keys, I don't need you.
(fast forwarding voice sounds)
Got it!
Alright. Sneak away, ya--ya--ya maroon.
Sneak!
Sneak like the wind!
(grunts)
(sings) Na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na!
Sneaking!
Na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na!
Really interesting conversation!
No need to turn around and look at the dead bodies you buried!
Na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na!
Okay, anyway....
So...
Is that annoying yet? (laughs)
Probably.
Oh, look, it's the other side of the chamber!
Alright.
They got a "snaper"...
And they got a really, really
well-trained soldier this time,
because he actually knows how to
lift his gun up in the air.
Don't mess with that guy...
Alright, so...
"Sneaking around and taking them by surprise might be slow,
but maybe it is less of a risk?"
"Attacking them head on is dangerous,
but this is what--" (laughs) "This is what they deserve!"
Do I deserve to go out, Rambo-style?
The answer is, "Hell yeah, I do!"
(screams)
(action music)
OH, I'M GONNA KILL YOU!
Oh, wow, that's some serious effects over there!
Heh. Down. Heh!
Oh, man, is this actually gonna work?
Up! Hubba...
Boom! Ohhhhhhhh!!!!
Uh...
Up!
Okay...
So--so--the--the quick-time event is the direction?
That the body is facing?
Oh, these--oh, these guys are gonna--(grunts)
That guy looked like just a kid.
Eh! He was just gonna take a nap, you know.
Man, I'm like, one shot, one kill Rambo here.
It is crazy.
Yup, check the windows, make sure they're all dead.
Are they all dead?
They look all dead.
Oh, oh! One more! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh...! (gunshot)
Bam! Oh...
Oh! I got him!
Yay! (laughs) I murdered everybody!
Hooray!
I'm a--
I--I literally am...I'm behind enemy lines,
and I'm picking off their entire army, one by one.
Uhhhh!!!!
Don't know how, yeah...
Splah, eh!
(laughs) The guy didn't want to get it on his friends,
so, he's like, "Should I shove it in his face...?"
"Eh, alright, on his--on his coat, there! Be a little nice!"
I bet he did--I bet there's outtakes on where he's like, shoveling right on his friend's face there!
'Cause, obviously this was made by--just like a group of friends who wanted to do a project,
and I really appreciate that!
I hope any of my stupid jokes
hasn't come across as me making fun of this...
I think this is really cool!
I really am enjoying myself here because,
it--it reminds me of what
I used to do. You know?
I--I didn't have video camera equipment like ths,
but, you know, just going out in the woods and dicking around,
it--it's just like, really cool.
And--and they didn't just make a movie out of it,
which is a lot--what a lot of people do,
they made a game out of it.
Did I have a nap?
What happened?
Did five months go by?
I missed it. I was rambling!
I'm Rambo-rambling!
I'm "Ramboboling"! (rimshot)
That's what I mean by stupid jokes. That's a bad one; it doesn't make anybody laugh.
You okay there, buddy?
Why'd it go all blue?
Oh! Oh! Sneak mode engaged!
I love it, like, standing up straight....
Sneak!
Oh, no, no one will see me now!
I'ma sneakin'!
Whoooaaa, shit, dude....
Is someone over there?
Oh, better not stand fully up!
No, notice me....
Even now, (laughs) even now going down the hill
he..like, all his sneak has just got a slight hunch in his back! Like...
Lowering my profile...
No one will see me.
Oh, shit.
So--so what's so "spoopy" about this building?
Something gonna happen?
Why'd you only bring a knife?!
Oh, hey!
Is he sleeping, too?
Why is everybody asleep, and also, stupid?
Oh, no, that guy might be dead.
That guy might be legitimately dead.
Uh oh.
Man, I'm making a lot of noise!
Boy, this--
This guy better be dead, because,
if--if he is not, then he has no excuse and he is about to be dead.
Oh! Oh! He is asleep!
Oh! Lulling his head from side to side!
I didn't have a single quick-time event there.
And that's when I was expecting it.
Okay...Oh, okay!
Alright then.
Uh...
Uh, BAM!
(laughs) He's like, "This guy's been through it before!"
This soldier--this soldier knows what's up!
He knows the deal!
He's like, "Ohhhh, caught sleeping again!"
"Oh, you want my hat!"
"Would you like my hat, sir?"
(lsughs)
Oh, geeze.
Yeah, e--even now he's like,  "Okay, let me get in a more comfortable position so that I can take a nice nap!"
"Thank you, sir! Everyone else hasn't killed me thus far!"
See..."I should go searching for ammunition and bandages first
in case I need to defend myself."
"Searching for food and water would make me
stay alive longer on my own."
Yeah, it seems like, more important, so let's do that one!
'Cause I got, like, 15 guns, there's gotta be some bullets in there!
I took out a outpost! They usually stock those bitches!
Okay, so, maybe...
Meh-beh....
I'm gonna find somethin'...
Meh-beh. Mey-beh...
But not a 100%.
Okay.
"Maybe I should risk it and go for it;
I can't lose too much time or I'll get caught."
"Maybe I should look through the windows, just to be sure there's no one there!"
Yeah, I'm gonna do the lin--the--the--the window-looking! You know...
Oh! I got an achievement!
I don't know what I did, but I got one!
Cool!
Ooooh, dere's food and water in dere.
Dere's some loverly food and water.
But why would he just be staying in the middle, there?
Yeah, let me stab this brick real quick!
Okey-dokey, then.
Maybe I should've just gone for it.
'Cause it doesn't seem to be anybody in there.
Also, I love the graffiti.
Wait! There's a cameraman in here!
Oh shit!
Oh, nevermind, then.
He's my friend.
He's my only friend.
Okay...
Man, I really could've just jumped in there!
Uh huh.
Well, that took a lot of time.
Eh! "I still have some spare time to look for ammunition."
Yeah! So what was the point of that!
Was that okay, then?
"Since the shovel bought me some time,
I can use it to find some bandages..." Hoooow?
I'll take the shovel, I guess?
I don't know how the shovel bought me any time...
Uh oh.
Am I gonna hit him with the shovel? Please tell me I'm gonna hit him with the shovel.
I really want to hit him with the shovel.
"He doesn't seem to be going off his patrol pathway;
Maybe I should just wait until he moves?"
"I don't have much time for waiting,
I guess I could go for a risk to find a different way in?"
Yeah, sure, let's do that, because...
Who knows?
May--I mean, everybody goes off to have conversations and take pisses around here,
so it couldn't be too bad.
Oh, who are you?
Aren't you the soldier that they just buried the other day?
Or other month? I can't tell time right now.
I don't know about you, but I...
I--I--I probab--I probably notice this.
Uh...Oh! Oh, no! Oh, nope, dead!
Dead.
100% dead.
Uh oh.
Uh! Uh! Uh!
Uh!
Uh! (laughs) Well...well...this is awkward!
(guard giving demands)
Man, they must really care about this soldier!
(fake accent) "Don't try anything stupid!"
How are you gonna grab it?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, okay. Alright, yeah. That...
Yeah, okay. Yeah, okay. Yeah.
Okay! Well, that--
That went better than expected!
I think about, right about now, they probably, you know, grab their guns up,
and start shooting at me...
Right--right about then, that would happen.
Okay. I'm being overly critical.
But, I mean, I just--I can't--I can't let that lie...
That's--that's just right in front of my face, there.
So I got ammunition, AND I got food and water...
Oh, and now they're coming for me!
And I got a helmet, somewhere...
Somewhere, I've got a helmet!
It's got a li--It's got an opener! I saw one!
Oh, was that a grenade?
Ah!
They spent their entire pyrotechnics budget right then and there. (heartbeats)
Wha--am I dead?
Am I okay?
Why's that guy got a sniper rifle at, literally, ten meters (laughing)...
...that was--that was not a smart choice on that guy's part.
Also, I'm not having anymore quick-time events.
(soldier shouting)
"Hey!" Ohhhhh!
It's me! Helmet guy!
Remember? We're friends!
Oh, this seems like a trap.
It seems like a trap.
D--Don't shoot!
Ooh, who is that?
Who are y---ohhh!
Uh, over?
Wait, the war??
Th--The war is over?!
"He is a part of this war, and in war there will be bloodshed.
...but maybe he deserves a chance?"
I'm gonna go with that!
I like helmet guy!
Helmet guy is my fav--
We're friends now!
Bro! Let's do it, like...
Arnold Schwarzenegger and that other guy!
Yeah!
Okay. Ow. What!
Wha--Wha--How long--did he--did he betray me?!?
Did he just punch me?
Give me a friendly punch?
Is this--is this your--is this my home now? (laughs)
Is this my home?
I have no idea!
Oh, man, I love this.
Like I said, I don't want any of my...
stupid jokes to get in the way of this,
or you think I don't like this,
because, no, I love this!
Because, I love the essence of it,
I love what it is.
It's--it's a group of friends trying to make something.
And, you know, they made it!
Like, they made it fully; they committed to it.
You know, it's not GREAT,
but it's a unique take on it, and it's done in a weird way.
Oh! And I got bandages!
Let me just drape it over like a Miss Universe sachet.
Yeah!
'Cause I won! I--I ended the war!
That guy, when he said it was over, the war is all over,
and everything will be a-okay, so...
This will do it.
It's Left 4 Dead-style, you just kind of like...
Swirl it around your body in a few locations and your HP goes up to maximum.
Or a little bit below maximum.
Uh oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, this injury is too grievous for a sachet. (laughs)
A sachet--a sachet to fix. (laughs)
I don't know why that was really funny to me!
It was just like--
like, like the--
like, the serious of the situation and the silliness of his two straps of bandages!
Yeah!!
Yes!
I love that. I love that!
I'm critical of a few aspects of it, but it's all in good fun.
I really love that!
Even though towards the end, it was like--there was less quick-time events,
but maybe they spent it all in that one rampage in,
but still, oh!
That was cool!
Like, legitimately! I'm not even saying that as like--like, (hesitantly) "It was good effort!"
No! Legitimately! That was cool!
It was something I've never done before, or I've never seen before,
and they tried something new and they made it.
They honestly went out, and they made it,
and I don't know how hard it was to make...
I mean, obviously, you gotta have, like, story boards for all the branching paths,
and what you want...
But they did the best with what they had,
and obviously, these guys are young, and they're trying something.
And it was till pretty cool!
Like, legitimately!
I--I--I don't wanna overstate.
I'm not criticizing, like, the deeper aspects of it...
"Ohhhh, the game play was all fubber-nucked!"
Like, obviously the game was not there,
But, for what it was at its very deep core...
was...cool.
And I like that.
So, either way, thank you everybody so much for watching!
Let me know what you thought of this--
err--let me know what you thought of a "Trip to Yugoslavia"
down in the comments below.
I'd love to visit Yugoslavia!
It sounds like a great place!
Maybe I will, someday, so...
Thank you again!
And as always, I will see you...in the next video.
Buh-bye!!!!
Wait a minute! Wait!
Bring it back! Bring the tape back!
(rewinding voice sounds)
Whoa! Wait a minute! Whoa!
I got the, "All lies" ending?
"You thought and attempted to kill a sleeping guard."
"You decided to arm yourself before attacking."
"No data"?
What did I miss there?
And, this is another thing!
Sort of, bring more about it...
Is like, it has choices!
"You chose to take the life of a patrolling guard."
Why does it say, "Total enemies killed: 0"?
"You took a risk and obtained a shovel.
You showed your enemies war."
Yeah, I--I'm pretty sure I killed a lot!
"Food and water were chosen over ammo and bandages."
"Surrendered soldier was spared."
Oh, that's the end of it.
Oh, that's weird!
Oh, that's cool, though!
So...I wonder how many different endings there were, and,
why did it say, "All lies"?
I--I think some of the tracking may have been a little bit off there, but...
You know, still not too bad.
I guess we're done here.
So...see you around. Bye!